Ah Houston?
We got a box office bomb here…
By all accounts, First Man is an excellent
film, filled with great performances from
stars like Ryan Gosling and Claire Foy.
So why isn't anyone going to see it?
Here's a look at why First Man has bombed
at the box office so far.
On paper, First Man should be a hit.
Ryan Gosling excels with another masterful
performance as Neil Armstrong, the first man
to walk on the moon, while rising star Claire
Foy has been earning accolades portraying
Armstrong's wife.
And the talent behind the camera is just as
impressive as the talent in front of it.
Damien Chazelle won the Best Director Oscar
for La La Land, and he's brought with him
Oscar-winning La La Land composer Justin Hurwitz
to provide the music.
And it's all based on an acclaimed biography
about the man at the center of one of the
greatest accomplishments in human history.
So why is it underperforming at the box office?
As the only major release of the weekend of
October 12th, First Man should have had smooth
sailing.
Instead, it got caught up in a crazy whirlwind
thanks to the battle between two holdover
releases from the previous week: A Star Is
Born and Venom.
Despite bad reviews, Venom managed to claw
its way to the top of the box office two weeks
in a row, but it was locked in a death struggle
the whole way with the acclaimed remake A
Star Is Born.
Between the flash of Lady Gaga's star power
and the over-the-top craziness of Tom Hardy's
alien anti-hero, Ryan Gosling's understated
quietude was drowned out in the noise — leaving
First Man the odd man out.
"Outstanding!
Now let’s bite all their heads off and pile
them up in the corner.
"
"why would we do that?"
The good news for First Man is that critically
acclaimed adult dramas often have long legs
compared to front-heavy superhero fare like
Venom.
Unfortunately for First Man, though, even
if Venom burns itself out at the box office,
there's another film waiting in the wings
to claim the box office crown: Halloween.
Earning a stellar $10 million from Thursday
night previews alone, Halloween is on pace
for an estimated $70 million opening weekend.
That's on pace to easily win the weekend and
likely bury First Man even further down the
depth chart.
When shiny new hits are dominating the conversation
every week, it's hard to generate buzz, even
if you're Buzz Aldrin.
First Man has already made back more than
half of its estimated $59 million budget,
so even if it hasn't been a huge hit so far,
it didn't exactly crash and burn, right?
Well, not so fast.
Because that figure doesn't take into account
one of the film's biggest costs: marketing.
While there's no way to know how much money
Universal has spent trying to get butts into
seats, typically advertising costs run about
half the cost of the film's budget.
Bump that $59 million figure up to $90 million
and the outlook starts to seem a lot less
rosy.
They say there's no such thing as bad press,
but while the drummed up controversies surrounding
First Man may not have hurt the film's box
office, they certainly haven't helped things
either.
So what are internet trolls pretending to
be upset about this time?
Well, because the finished cut doesn't highlight
the planting of the American flag in the moon
landing scene, some people felt First Man
wasn't nationalistic enough.
And needless to say, those same people weren't
too pleased when star Claire Foy used a Washington
Monument metaphor to suggest that President
Donald Trump is, quote, "the giant penis of
America."
"you're a bunch of boys!
Making models out of balsa wood.
You don’t have anything under control."
Even though First Man has had a disappointing
debut, there's still hope that it will eventually
turn a profit — or even become a hit.
That's because we've literally seen this before.
In 1983, The Right Stuff, which was also about
America's space program, debuted to poor box
office figures and limped along in theaters
for weeks… until it earned eight Academy
Award nominations, generating huge buzz and
leading to a commercial resurgence.
Despite being released in October, The Right
Stuff's biggest box office weekend was at
the end of February following a huge re-release
prior to the Oscars.
With Academy Award buzz already building around
Gosling and Foy, it looks like Universal's
best hope is to play the long game and hope
First Man catches fire on re-entry.